[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا جن الليل خلال هذه الايام فسنشاهد
المع الاجرام السماويه المسماه بالزهره
فلما جن عليه الليل راى كوكبا قال هذا ربي
فلما افل قال لا احب الافلين وسنشاهد ايضا
اكبر افرادا المجموعه الشمسيه المسمى
بالمشتري فالمشتري والزهره هي زينه السماء
ان زينا سماء الدنيا بزينه الكواكب وخلال
هذه الايام سيتقارب كوكب المشتري مع
الزهره وهذا تقارب يسميها العرب بالاقتران
قران المشتري زحلا يرجى لايقاظ النواظر من
كراهه تقضى الناس جيلا بعد جيل وخلفت
النجوم كما تراها فالمشتري والزهره وسهيل
والمرزم نشاهدها بالعين المجرده طوال شهر
شعبان قال له شهر مارس يضاف اليها نادر في
منتصف الشهر القمري البدر يكمل في كل شهر
مره وهلال وجهك في كل يوم كامل من ذا الذي
اهداك اجمل صوره وحباك نورا في الفضاء
وجملك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]